we always learn about American founding
fathers who had slaves you know this was
a practice that was carried over from
centuries but we never really learned
about the Islamic slave trade about the
slave trade that occurred in Africa and
still occurs in portions of the world
yeah well you've had two really
important things there number one is
we're tearing out all these statutes
because they're associated with slavery
wait a minute this entire relate
religions been doing slavery since 600
or so I mean does that mean we tear down
every mosque because today they are
still active in slavery the Muslim world
is still active in slavery to this day
right right right now
I mean we've that different story but we
can go through that later so if you're
after slavery well let's look around
let's not go after the founding fathers
alone and by the way while we're at it I
love doing this we all summer long we
have groups of college kids come in for
two weeks and we do all this kind of
training and we're the truth we want you
to know truth the good the bad the ugly
of America we want you to know it's
actually doesn't matter what Professor
says you look at original document read
the Quran yourself right so we do this
kind of stuff on truth and what we'll do
is we put a picture of the signers of
the Declaration out in front of those
kids started a two-week session say tell
me everybody up there you can name that
own slaves because we know they're all
racist bigots and slave owners right
everybody can name Thomas Jefferson and
I have not in five years of doing this
have not had anybody named a second
slave owner of signers declaration
either Thomas Jefferson so wait a minute
timeout Jefferson owned slaves so that
means they're all fifty-six racist and
biggest of slaves that what you're
telling me and they recognize that's a
pretty fallacious argument right and
what we can do is we can show them the
out of the 56 signers of declaration
only 14 were pro-slavery three out of
four started abolitionists so that I
spoke against slavery fought against it
led against it but we get the exception
not the rule that's the way we teach
American history today right you want to
be fair about history say okay
one-fourth of the founding fathers are
pro-slavery they came primarily out of
Georgia North Carolina South Carolina
let's go north whole different ball game
you have blacks elected to office in
1768 in New Hampshire re-elected for 49
years a different political positions
you have a number of black heroes in the
American
two major paintings done of them that
nobody ever sees today because we don't
think the black said in your role in the
revolution right so we get this
politically correct nonsense going with
its on Islam or the founding fathers or
slavery by the way we don't talk about
political rect every single statue
that's come down has been of a Democrat
activist that was a racial bigot context
does matter and you talk about this one
quarter obviously pro-slavery to the
rest were not at a time where it was
considered really revolutionary to the
anti-slavery this is idea that you know
if you look at slavery look at the
timeline abolished in England long
before the United States but they don't
talk about the British Empire they don't
sighs they were people were the radicals
yeah the anti a are responsible globally
even though they're still exist Labor's
any but in the Western world for
single-handedly ending slavery as we
know a lot of people don't we don't get
credit for that it was a practice
carried over so um what about when
people say the guy who wanted to remove
the monuments therein at George
Washington Park they say George
Washington owned slaves owned slaves
franklin hamilton and they they go
through the list pretty much everyone
they saw in the john adam is special
yeah we are so undereducated day we love
platitudes willie like presidents on
single phrases like you know change or
lean forward or whatever yeah make
America great what does that mean you
know I don't care I'm elected depressing
on that and so we're into these little
bitty platitudes that we we know so
little about and in Virginia I mentioned
that Jefferson was a slave owner of
Virginia and he wasn't I think 181
slaves nothing the sort like that
interesting thing he was it was illegal
for him to freed his own slaves his own
slaves that he could not do it by
Virginia law and so what happens is
Jefferson is the guy who who tried to in
slavery nationally he tried first in
Virginia they voted him down he
introduced the National anti slavery lot
lost by one vote Jefferson said Oh would
the God that one heart would have
changed we could ended slavery
nationally came to them one of Oh
Jefferson did that Jefferson for nearly
60 years was a huge leader in the
anti-slavery movement which is why up
until and through MLK black civil rights
leaders were praising Jefferson for all
he did to try to end slavery right down
today always so Jefferson owned slaves
she's a bad guy wait a minute state law
wouldn't the same with George Washington
George Washington had a loophole in
state law that says when you die you can
free your slaves got it he did and then
they close that loophole by Jeffers in
the soap so guy can't have that we got
to close that loophole and so Virginia
you'll find most of the Virginia
founding fathers were anti-slavery
matter of fact George Mason one of the
55 guys who wrote the Constitution he
didn't sign it for two reasons number
one it didn't have a bill of rights so
he he wanted bill rights he's called the
father bill right right number two
George Mason from Virginia didn't sign
the Constitution because it did not
abolish slavery he's a slave owner you
want to in slavery for your slaves now
I'm from Virginia can't do that
I want the Constitution to abolish like
so you got all these guys that actually
even some of them own slaves
that didn't want slaves that were huge
anti-slavery guys you'll never get that
nuanced today all we do is platitudes
and soundbite it would be like taking
everyone today who's forced to pay a
carbon tax and say they were Pro carbon
tax when we're actively fighting against
it like no no is the law we believe in
the rule of law we believe using the law
to try and fight it to try and change
the law to try and amend the law a lot
of people don't give them credit for the
good stuff that they did if you hate
slaves you don't free them upon death
but I know we're asleep with them there
is some of that some personal decisions
people were imperfect but I got by the
way let's hit that for just a second
because we're alluding to Thomas
Jefferson here right I mean Jefferson
slept with slaves what you've got is
does anybody ever pay attention to the
fact that they never use Jefferson's DNA
and that DNA test I mean they did that
in November of 1998 and Joseph Ellis
announced that Jefferson slept with the
slaves and the guy who did the the DNA
test in Eugene foster we talked to him
we talked to him we did the second DNA
testing they never use Jefferson's DNA
he said I told them that I told him it
doesn't prove how do they make the claim
then well what happened was there were
26 Jefferson males in the area and they
used one of Jefferson's uncle's and
since way back then we believed that it
was Thomas Jefferson's younger brother
read often did that yeah got that DNA
got the connection well that's a
Jefferson that means it was Thomas no
there was 26 Jefferson males living in
Monticello
you don't as men
in fact the first child from from
Hemmings was a guy named Thomas and the
newspapers of the day they said they she
named it Thomas because it named after
Thomas Jefferson they checked the DNA
and and this was 1998 the DNA they
tested was of Thomas the first son of
Sally Hemings there was no Jefferson DNA
at all in Thomas nowhere she had five
children they found some Jefferson DNA
and the fourth child and that's the one
that we've always said was was Jefferson
you know the brother Randolph that goes
back 200 years but they say well
Jefferson DNA it's got to be Thomas no
the DNA testing showed just the opposite
I smell a new series CSI Jefferson from
the full show Daily Show at lotta with
credit calm slash mug club or it's
available exclusively $69 a year that's
less than six dollars a month less than
two expensive cups of coffee or you can
feed an African child but just buy
coffee or join the Mudd Club Daily Show
lighter with credit calm slash mug Club
see you there don't feed children